Oh bug head we don't want to make things
awkward but we're dying to know the
truth are things weird between you guys
now that Charles is in the picture we
mean I'm Charles your brother sure you
guys aren't related by blood but you
share a half sibling who is equal parts
your brother if you're Charles you and I
are also brothers junk head that's right
that has to be a little weird and what's
that we hear about FP and Alice
rekindling their romance yeah that sort
of changes the entire dynamic so what
are you going to do bug head and don't
you dare say break up
Riverdale season 4 is coming to a small
screen near you and it just might be the
wildest season yet watch until the end
to find out which character isn't going
to make it past Halloween a touching
tribute actor Luke Perry sudden passing
shocked everyone who loved and knew him
the Riverdale cast spoke out about their
dear friend when the incident was made
public but Riverdale has yet to address
the actors passing well that's about to
change guys the TV series creator
Roberto aguirre-sacasa has confirmed
that season four will pay Luke tribute
in a very special episode titled in
memoriam the episode will highlight Fred
Andrews death so be ready to shed some
serious tears it's all about Tony topaz
now that he's gone I think it's like
sweet pea I think there's only one path
and one solution violence
Sheryl's badass girlfriend has been on
the show's front lines for quite a while
now but according to Roberto
aguirre-sacasa season 4 will focus more
on Tony topaz than ever before since the
main characters expected to pass away on
Halloween night Vanessa Morgan fans are
happy to know that Tony will have a
major role throughout the new season so
she's presumed to be safe you're not
over Betty and I'm not interested in
being anybody's rebound senior year
Archie Veronica Betty Jughead and the
entire gang are officially seniors so we
can expect to see our heroes in a school
setting more often than not unlike
season 3 which hardly ever showcased the
core for sitting at their desks season
4s 5 is expected to have a high school
tinge to it but one major character will
be leaving Riverdale behind
and no we're not talking about Josie but
more on that later there's a new
principal in town Waldo Weatherby has
been the Riverdale principal since
season 1 but that's about to change
despite one being an understanding and
compassionate principal Weatherbee took
a dive off the deep end when he joined
the farm so Archie and the gang can
expect a brand new principal to pick up
where Weatherby left off is everything
okay with Cheryl she's in for might also
focus on Cheryl blossoms mental health
and it's slow decline although cheryl
has always demonstrated a very strong
morale her sanity might have hit the
ceiling when she was exposed to her twin
brother's corpse we know for a fact that
Cheryl is going to bring Jason's body
home and speak to it like it's alive and
well so yeah something is seriously
going to be wrong with Cheryl in season
4 auntie Cheryl on top of struggling
with her mental health
Cheryl might also be tasked with looking
after the twins since Penelope blossom
is no longer in the picture and Polly
Cooper is unfit to raise her children
the task might fall unto auntie Cheryl
but the twins will undoubtedly be shared
between Alice Betty and Cheryl after all
Cheryl has a lot on her plate the
long-lost brother season three ended
with Betty and Jughead meeting their
half-brother Charles Smith during the
comic-con event Cole Sprouse mentioned
that Charles and Betty storyline would
be a lot more intertwined than Jughead
and Betty's so we can expect to see a
lot of Charles in season four and Betty
is probably going to help her brother
solve some crimes
she's your everyday Nancy Drew after all
Jughead is going to prep school the core
for our getting separated once again but
this time it's Jughead who's ditching
town after riding and submitting his
gargoyle Kings story to a writing
contest a certain teacher will reach out
to Jughead to take him into a prep
school although Jughead won't be
attending Riverdale high with Archie
Betty and Veronica he will be coming
home on the weekends so we won't miss
him too much bike head your brother's
alive he's
FBI agent it's our half brother and it's
pretty crazy right there's no doubt
about it Betty and Jughead belong
together but there's going to be trouble
in paradise in season four
Charles arrival is going to shake up
like his foundation sharing a
half-brother is a pretty strange thing
to have in common with your lover so we
can expect some tension between Betty
and Doug on top of that joke head will
be out of town more often than not so
they might even drift apart but we have
faith that they'll get together again
Alice and FP play my sweet innocent
daughter live in sin and that suit can
you call a trailer just when we thought
that Betty and jag had a fighting chance
their parents go and ruin it all it
looks like things might heat up between
Alice and FP now that Edgar ever never
and Gladys Jones are out of the picture
Alice and SP can finally rekindle their
romance while we're totally on board it
does make things extra awkward for
buckhead Halloween episode the cast of
Riverdale has made it clear that someone
will be passing away on the night of
Halloween season four will have a
handful of deaths and fans are going
crazy with theories according to Lily
Reinhardt someone very important is
going to die however she did mention
that Betty Jughead Archie Veronica and
Cheryl were all going to be safe so who
do you think is going to kick the bucket
on Halloween night tell us what your
theories are in the comment section
below
and that's a wrap don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]